hi everyone welcome to this exciting
session by simplyloan
today we have a really interesting topic
for you in this video
we'll be analyzing the upcoming united
states presidential election using
twitter sentiment analysis in python
in the course of this session we will
understand in brief about the upcoming
election
the candidates fighting the 2020 u.s
election and throw light on the result
of the 2016 new year's election
we look at the election forecast by some
of the popular news agencies
as well as pole analysis websites such
as 538
before we begin i want to make it clear
that this video is solely for learning
purposes
we had simply learned to not lean
towards any party in the united states
or are biased towards any candidate the
analysis is based on what people have
tweeted and we will understand the mood
and sentiment of the public
the main objective of this video is to
help you understand how to extract
tweets from twitter handles
using python libraries store it in a csv
file and perform textual analysis
the results obtained are purely based on
the data that we have collected
let's begin
the battle for the 2020 u.s presidential
election has begun
with the 59th united states presidential
election scheduled to be held on the 3rd
of november 2020
this will decide who will be in the
white house for the next four years
all 435 seats in the united states house
of representatives
35 of the 100 seats in the united states
senate and office of the president of
the united states will be contested
both the republican party and the
democratic party have nominated their
respective president and vice
presidential candidates
the incumbent president donald trump is
the republican nominee
while the 47th vice president of the
united states joe biden is the
democratic party's nominee
the current vice president mike pence is
the republican party's vice presidential
nominee
and is running for a second term in
office
senator kamala harris of california was
chosen by joe biden as his
running mate on 11th of august 2020.
now let's see the results of the last
u.s presidential election in 2016.
the republican ticket of businessman
donald trump and indiana governor mike
pence
had defeated the democratic ticket of
former secretary of state hillary
clinton and u.s senator from virginia
tim kaine donald trump received a total
of 304 electoral votes
while hilary clinton got 227 electoral
votes
a significant number of central states
in the united states were swept
by the republican party it was
surprising to see that donald trump
getting nearly 46.4 popular vote
as compared to hillary clinton who got
48.5
votes donald trump's victory came after
crucial wins
in the battleground streets of florida
ohio iowa
north carolina and pennsylvania
will donald trump be re-elected to the
white house or are we going to see a new
president and
vice president of the united states is
the big question
let's see what our pollsters have to say
and what has been their forecast for the
upcoming election
according to 538 donald trump has not
gained ground since the final debate on
22nd of october
at this moment joe biden is favored to
win the election and he leads in both
national and state pools
the economist is analyzing polling
economic and demographic data to predict
the u.s elections
their model thinks joe biden is very
likely to beat donald trump in the
electoral college
as per their forecast joe biden has 96
percent chance of winning the electoral
college
and this 99 percent chance of biden
winning the most votes
the democrats have 75 chance of
controlling the senate
while the republicans have around 25
percent
the democrats are highly likely to keep
their majority in the house of
representatives
now according to the guardian joe biden
is leading donald trump
in the national polls for the
presidential election but to keep in
mind
this does not guarantee the democratic
candidate joe biden's victory
hillary clinton also had a clear lead
over donald trump in the polls for
almost the entire
2016 campaign she ended up losing the
electoral college
now the bbc forecast tells that biden is
leading national presidential polls
with 51 percent he has hovered around 50
percent in recent months
and has had a 10 point lead on occasions
so clearly joe biden is set to be the
next u.s president
let's wait and watch what happens on the
3rd of november
the voters of america will decide on 3rd
of november whether donald trump remains
in the white house for another 4 years
let's perform a two-day sentiment
analysis to understand the sentiments of
people tweeting about donald trump and
joe biden
by tagging them in their tweets we have
our code implemented already
i'll run through each line of code and
explain our analysis in detail
the objective is to check the polarity
of each tweet to figure out if it's
positive
negative or neutral we'll compare the
tweets of donald trump and joe biden
to see who people are favoring the most
finally
we learn to create a word cloud i have
already extracted the tweets and stored
them in two separate csv files
it takes some time to fetch 10 000
tweets hence it won't be possible for me
to show it to you live
if you want to know how we extracted the
tweets for donald trump and joe biden
then please put your email ids in the
comments section of the video
we'll share the code file and the source
file with you now you would need to
install the tweepy library
which the twitter keys and access tokens
and then authenticate the twitter api
i've extracted 5000 tweets each for
donald trump and joe biden
converted into a data frame and stored
it in a csv file
so let me open and show you both the
files so here is my data set for donald
trump on the top you can see trump
underscore data 5000 which means there
are
5 000 tweets here the first column
has the number of tweets it starts from
0 and
goes all the way to 4999
the next column is the text column which
has the content of the tweet
you can see they have tagged
at the rate real donald trump there are
links as well
there are special characters like
emoticons
and the third column is the user
which means it's the username who had
put that tweet
similarly i have another data for
biden you can see these are
for joe biden and here you can see the
content they have tagged kamala harris
also
similarly we have the user username now
let me take you straight to my jupyter
notebook
where i have implemented the code okay
so first and foremost
let's import all the required libraries
so we have the numpy library for
numerical computation
then we have the pandas library for data
manipulation
next we are importing two libraries
matplotlib and c
bond for data visualization then we have
text blob and word cloud to get the
sentiment and to build the word cloud
and finally we are importing the plotly
library for creating graphs
let me run this cell in the current cell
we'll import the data sets using read
underscore csv function
present in the pandas library so i have
passed in my
location where the data file is so i
placed it on my desktop
and the index underscore
col parameter or column parameter refers
to the columns to be used as the row
labels of the data frame
here 0 indicates that the first column
will be used
as row labels let me run it
ok now we have imported both the data
files
let me go ahead and print the shape of
one of the data frames so i'll write
print
let's say we'll check the shape of biden
data frame so i'll write
print biden dot shape
i'll hit shift enter you can see there
are
5000 rows and there are two columns one
is the text column and the next column
is the user column
now let me go ahead and print
the head of the data sets so the head
function will
return the first five rows i'll write
trump dot
head you can see
these are the first five rows from the
trump
data frame and similarly if you want to
check for
biden i can write biden dot head
you can see it here now you can also use
the info method so let me
show you that you can write drum dot
info
and this is the result so it tells there
are 5000 entries from 0 to
4999 there are two columns
and these are the number of rows
and similarly you have the data types
okay moving ahead in the next cell i'm
displaying the
200th tweet present in the trump data
frame
so i have my data frame name mentioned
then i have
my text column and inside one more
square bracket i have put
200 which means i want to see what's
there in the
200th row if i hit enter
so you can see this was the tweet fake
[ __ ]
fake president next
let me show you the tweet number 1000
for
biden so i'll write biden
and inside square brackets i'll give the
text column
and the number is 1000
if i hit shift enter so this is the
tweet
now the text blob function is used in
natural language processing
the sentiment property returns a named
tuple in the form of
sentiment in brackets polarity
and subjectivity let's check the
sentiment
of the 200th tweet made for donald trump
if i hit shift enter you can see this
was the polarity
now minus 0.399 means
the polarity was negative and you can
see the subjectivity is around
0.933 similarly
let's check for biden's tweet number
1000
so i'll write text
blob which is my function name and
inside brackets i'll give biden
then pass in my column name that is text
and i'll give the row number which is
1000
and then i'll give the
parameter or the attribute sentiment
if i hit shift enter you can see the
polarity and the subjectivity
now moving ahead here
i have defined a function that will add
another column called polarity
to our two data frames trump and biden
let me run this okay
in the next cell i have used the apply
function that will return the polarity
based on the tweets
you can see we have the apply function
this might take some time to run it okay
we are done now
let me now display the top five rows of
the data frame
so what i'll do is i'll click on this
cell
go to insert and i'll hit
insert cell below let's do one more
okay now here i'll display the head of
the data frame once again so that you
can see the polarity column added
you can see it here so for donald trump
we have the polarity you can see the
tweet and the polarity
now 0.0 which means these are neutral
minus is negative and anything
that's in positive value indicates it's
a
positive tweet or it has positive
polarity
similarly let's see for biden
i'll write biden dot head
okay so here you can see the polarity
for biden
now this point five means it's a
positive tweet
okay now i want to create
another column called expression where
we will classify the tweets as positive
negative or neutral based on the
polarity value
so i have used the np dot where function
and the condition
we have here is if polarity is greater
than 0
it's a positive tweet else if it is less
than 0
it's a negative to it and if the
polarity is equal to 0
it means it's a neutral tweet let me run
this
okay so here you can see we have the
column called expression
and it has classified the polarity based
on
negative neutral as well as positive
similarly let's do the same for biden
data frame as well
okay
before moving ahead if you want to get
access to the source code and the data
sets we have used in this demo
then please put your email address in
the chat section
we'll send it to you via mail also
please subscribe to simply learn channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from simply loan
in the next cell of code we have another
function
that will basically help us creating a
bar plot based on the expression column
from both the data frames so this is my
user defined function name and it has
two
parameters reviews and title
you can see we have
grouped the expression column and found
out the count using the count function
then we have created or converted it
into a list
similarly below you can see here
we have defined the color for the bars
using rgb values now let me run it
okay so we have successfully created our
user defined function
now let me go ahead and call the
function and pass in my two parameters
reviews and title
so here we have the function name and
under reviews we have the data frame
named trump
and the title we have given is analysis
for trump
let me run this okay
so you can see we have a horizontal bar
plot
on the top you can see the title of the
plot which is analysis for trump
and as per the tweets
it has classified as positive neutral or
negative
if i hover over you can see there were
2831 neutral tweets
1211 positive tweets and similarly there
were
958 negative tweets for donald trump
now let me call that
function once again so i'll write exp
underscore
graph which is my function name
then i'll pass in my parameters this
time i'll take biden
and the title i'll put is analysis
for biden
if i run it okay you can see the
plot for biden now if i hover over
there were 1290 positive tweets
for biden and 747 negative tweets
okay let's
scroll down now let me check
the number of rows that have polarity
equal to 0
the number of rows that have polarity
less than 0 and greater than 0 for both
the data frames
using the dot shape attribute
so first we have for trump
now equal to equal to 0 means we are
checking the total number of
neutral tweets you can see the result
now let's check for biden we have the
result
below let me run it
okay
now we'll drop those columns that have a
polarity equal to 0 from both the data
frames and display the shape
you can see we have the condition
mentioned
and we have also used the drop function
so all the neutral tweets will be
deleted and i'm printing the
shape of the data frame
there you go so out of the 5000 tweet it
has deleted all the neutral tweets or
dropped all the neutral treats and this
is the final result the current cell
we have defined another function called
balanced underscore data
now this will help us get an equal
number of rows and columns and delete a
specified number of rows
let me run it all right
now i'll call that function to delete
169 rows from the trump's data frame
and 37 rows from biden's data frame
this will help us subset the data frames
you can see we have now
2 000 tweets from each of the data
frames
up next we'll create some visualizations
to analyze the textual data
so first i'm using the c-bond library
and creating
a distribution plot for donald trump
if i hit shift enter you can see
this is the distribution plot this there
are bars at the back and there's a trend
line
okay similarly let me now create a box
plot
so this is a box plot here you can see
there are some outliers
now let me add a few cells
below so that i can show that plot for
biden
so i'll write sns dot
i'll use the function dist plot
and under this plot i'll give
biden underscore subset
and i'll pass in my column that is
polarity let me run it
so this is the distribution plot for joe
biden
and now
let me also create the box plot so i'll
use the c bond library and the box plot
function
i'll pass in my data frame which is
biden underscore subset
and i'll give my column name that is
polarity
i'll run it so here you can see the box
plot for joe biden
let me tell you how you can create a
cross table using the group by function
so before coming to this cell of code
let me insert
cell above okay
now using group by function you can
create a cross table
so i'll use the trump underscore
subset data frame
and then i'll give my group by function
and inside group by function i'll give
my expression column
and i'll count the number of expressions
if i run this you can see this is a
cross table
similarly you can do it for joe biden as
well
i'll just replace the names i'll write
biden and the rest is
the same you can see
this is the cross table for biden
underscore subset
now moving ahead
let's find the polarity percentage for
negative and positive tweets
to do this i have defined a function
called
poll underscore percent and we have two
parameters declared
subset and total
let me run this okay
now here i am calling the above defined
function and printing the polarity
percentage for biden and trump
and i have mentioned my two parameters
subset
and the total number so these are the
values
moving ahead
now let's create a bar graph that will
show the negative and positive polarity
percentage for donald trump
and joe biden
let me hit shift enter you can see
we have a really good bar
graph now if i hover the mouse cursor
you can see donald trump had 27.825
percent of positive tweets and
22.17 negative similarly joe biden had
31.6 positive tweets and
18.4 negative tweets
now we want to find the public sentiment
based on trump and biden tweets
let me run this two cells first
okay now for donald trump
the total positive polarity is a
combination of trump's
total positive percentage and biden's
negative percentage
similarly for joe biden the total
positive polarity is a combination of
guidance
total positive percentage and trump's
negative percentage let me run this
you can see the result here next
let's plot a horizontal bar graph to
visualize the public sentiment
we have our x and y labels defined
we also have set our bar colors with the
help of
rgb values and we have the title as well
now if i go up you can see this is the
public sentiment
so 26.88 is the percentage that is in
favor of
joe biden and for donald trump you have
23.11
coming down
now in the next cell of code we have a
user defined function that will
basically
plot a table which has the most positive
tweets for donald trump and joe biden
the condition we are checking is that
the polarity should be
equal to one so if it's close to one or
equal to one which means
the tweet has positive polarity
let me run it
okay now let me go ahead and call the
function now let me scroll over to the
top
you can see these are the top five
positive tweets for donald trump and
here you can see the top 5 positive
tweets for joe biden
likewise let's check the polarity for
most negative
tweets here the condition will be the
polarity should be
equal to -1 which means it's highly
negative
let me run it okay
now let's go ahead and call the function
negative tweets so i'll write neg
underscore tweets
and then inside bracket i'll give my
parameters
which is trump underscore subset
and then i'll give my title as
negative tweets
for donald trump
okay now let's copy this
we'll also check for joe biden so i'll
just replace this with
biden and let's say
negative to it for joe biden
let's run it okay if i go on top
here you can see the top
negative tweets for donald trump and
similarly we have the
top five negative tweets for joe biden
all right finally
let's see how to create a word cloud now
word cloud is a method to show
which words are most frequently
occurring among the given text
i have defined a function called word
cloud you can see here
and it has two parameters data and title
inside the built-in function or the word
cloud function
we have mentioned the max font size
the maximum words scale value there's
also
background color which is white okay
let's run it now this will create
a word cloud so let me go ahead and
call the word cloud function and pass in
the arguments
so i'll write word cloud which is my
user defined function
and i'll give my parameters trump
underscore
subset comma i'll give my title as
word cloud
for donald trump
let's see donald trump tweet replies
okay similarly
let's do it for joe biden
write word cloud biden underscore
subset and then i'll give the title
as word
cloud for
joe biden to it
replies okay let me run it
there you go you can see we have a nice
word cloud so on the top you can see the
title which says word cloud for donald
trump
tweet replies so here you can see
some of the words like real donald trump
then there's
precedent love right
all these similarly if i scroll down you
can see the word cloud for joe biden
tweet replies you can see
there's the handle joe biden falls there
are some
other words like do taxes believe
even will it's fact
and you can see kamala had his name here
okay
now that brings us to the end of this
demo on twitter sentiment analysis using
text data
you learned how to classify tweets and
find the polarity
we also looked at how to create
interesting visualizations
with this data and understood the mood
of the public
finally you saw how to create a word
cloud that had
the most frequently occurring words in
the tweets
if you want to get the source file and
the source code that we have used in
this demo
then please put your email ids in the
comment section we hope you enjoyed
watching this video
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
thank you for watching and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here